early may is around the corner and that
means Derby season the third annual day
at the Derby event put on by Helping
Hands of Vegas Valley is a fun
fundraiser to help our seniors in need
here in Clark County development
director Nina Gallagher is here to tell
us all about the hats the mint juleps
and all the other fun things at the
event nice to see you good to see you
look dapper you look beautiful in that
hat and you did it yourself I did it is
gorgeous I love the hats at this event
because the ladies look so elegant and
Regal tell us what happens at the Derby
event where is it this year this year
we're hosting our third annual day at
the Derby at the Springs Preserve it's
out on the amphitheater so out on the
green amongst the trees and all the
beautiful things that are blooming right
now yeah and you'll expect to arrive to
A champagne blast yes filled with a more
better I say with a one carat man-made
diamond
um
it's a champagne wall put on by Minden
Jewelers yes so it's an opportunity to
also receive a raffle ticket by
purchasing a glass of champagne where
you may win a half carat pair of diamond
earrings oh that sounds fabulous so lots
of fun raffle prizes lots of live
auction items to bid on like a trip to
Cabo trip to Cabo including a yacht for
12. oh oh my goodness that sounds
fabulous and so talk about Helping Hands
of Vegas Valley what does the non-profit
do who do you serve so Helping Hands in
Vegas Valley is a nonprofit that serves
seniors that are 60 and over and we
provide a number of services that are
free to those
seniors and it's everything from
Transportation respite care minor home
repair pantry and now nutrition program
okay so you pack and deliver groceries
how many seniors a year do you serve
currently we're serving 4 000 a month a
month a month that's a lot of groceries
and so you need to keep the pantry
stocked this fundraiser brings in the
money that helps complete and and
provide all those Services all year long
for free to every senior succeed free
yeah and there's a lot of there's a lot
of need out there more seniors I'm sure
every week every month that need help
the population continues to grow in Las
Vegas and so as you said the need is
evident and so we look for volunteers
and Community Support to continue these
services so the event is Saturday May
6th the tickets still available how much
tickets are still available there are
125 dollars come and visit
www.hhovv for your tickets and we'd love
to see you even at Prime is for most
fabulous hat most Dapper man best
dressed couple so put on your best Derby
outfits yes and show up May 6 3 30 to 7
30. it's gonna be a lot of fun full
disclosure I am on the board of Helping
Hands of Vegas Valley great to see you
love the hat I got some work to do if
I'm going to show up next to her all
right good day Las Vegas we'll be right
back